Hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha.
We scientifically analyzed
all of these ingredients and created a perfect food plan that allows us to consume them efficiently every
day.As a result, we arrived at the ultimate menu.
Of course, the taste is the same every day. With this, it
's easy to manage seasonings, so there's no waste.
Unfortunately, it's not cooking, it's science.
It's a direct hit
[music]
I really did this in 10 minutes
Then it's already amazing The ingredients should be the same, but it's completely different from my ultimate menu
.  It's an honor to be able to make dishes that suit your palate.
You're good at cooking,
aren't you?